hey guys I'm Lucy and welcome to in two
minutes now the next big expansion for
destiny the taken King is out next week
and here's where I've got to hold my
hands up and admit kind of lapsed player
I did play pretty extensively when it
first launched but in the end I
gradually drifted away from destiny but
I've always maintained an interest it's
hard to ignore it with people talking
about the latest nerfs tweaks additions
and let's not forget the time at the
gala horn trended worldwide on Twitter
destiny year too seems like a really
different destiny to the one that I
played and a bungee offering this one
time use item that jumps you up a few
levels so you're ready for the taken
king which has got me thinking do I jump
back in now here's a few reasons why I
might Destiny's loveling system was
always just sort of bizarre using XP
gained while playing you'd left luck
normally until you hit 20 from there
your level was then tied to the light
level of whatever it was you were
wearing it's a confusing system that's
thankfully being replaced by a more
traditional one you earn XP in the game
and that's what determines your level
progression the light level of your
equipment now represents your characters
overall power so it could be that you're
the same level as your friend but
because your equipment is better you're
more powerful than them it's a system
that's the best of both worlds there's
still the chance to level up normally
but you can also delve in deeper if you
want to I'll admit I got a bit bored of
my Guardians moveset after a while
countless hours of the same old thing
will do that to you but in the taken
King each Guardian class will now be
getting a new subclass that offers new
moves skills and abilities the hunter
can utilize the Night Stalker Destiny's
first true support class warlocks who to
storm caller will get lightning focused
offensive powers and Titans can get
their hands on the hammer of Sol super
so there's a little something for
everyone that's really gonna change
things up the taken King is changing
various systems to cut down on the
infamous destiny grind as well as being
able to carry 16 bounties you no longer
have to trudge all the way back to the
tower to turn them in not only that but
the obtuse currency system is also being
overhauled Vanguard marks earned through
PvE and crucible marks earned through
pvp are finally
instead there's one currency that's in
and that's legendary marks that you can
earn regardless of the mode you play so
you're not being penalized for not
playing every game mode and finally a
moment of silence please everyone's
favorite dinkle bot has been replaced
while lauded for his role as Tyrion
Lannister in Game of Thrones Peter
Dinklage sadly didn't capture the hearts
of Guardians worldwide who criticized
his lackluster performance as the ghost
instead he's been completely replaced
with gaming's nolan north nolan north
and while destiny story was nothing to
write home about explain mostly via
online only grimoire cards destiny 2
point 0 will have more of a constructed
narrative with year one story missions
being reorganized to better fit the main
storyline so while the overall story
might be better let's just hope that
they've worked on some of those lines I
don't even have time to explain why I
don't have time to explain so those are
some of the big changes coming to
destiny in the taken king now if you're
a lapse player like me is that enough to
get you back in or if you're a long-term
player what's keeping you playing be
sure to let me know in the comment box
below or find me on Twitter I'm at Lucy
James games I'll see you next time
you